alors vous avez grandi dans une fratrie
de 7 enfants d'une famille originaire du
nord du Maroc
vous parlez d'une famille très
traditionnaliste avec des coutumes du
site farfelus et puis à l'âge de 18 ans
vous apprenez par votre cousine que
votre cousin marocain voulait demander
votre main
on vous explique que c'était comme ça
dans la famille on se marie qu'entre
nous et lors de vacances au Maroc juste
avant votre retour en France
votre père vous a imposé un mariage avec
cet homme comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cette ce moment
j'ai été trahi
je pense que je ne réalisais pas
l'ampleur
des choses à ce moment-là
ou vraiment là où ça m'a vraiment ouvert
les yeux c'est qu'on va emmener chez le
médecin me faire un certificat
et puis voilà j'essaie de l'aide
j'ai écouté une demi-sœur qui me disait
de le faire semblant de et arriver en
France
vous pouvez rentrer au plus vite en fait
même si les papiers je ne savais même
pas ce que je signais je ne savais même
pas que c'était pour faire enclencher la
procédure
[Musique]
je précise quand vous parlez de
certificat vous parlez de certificat de
virginité c'est ça donc le médecin vous
dit que voilà votre père est votre
tuteur c'est lui qui voulait imposer
donc vous pouvez rien faire je n'avais
pas le choix voilà de force on le fera
si même si vous refusez
et alors ce moment qui est terrible une
fois que que vous retournez en France
votre famille a dû partir au Maroc pour
s'occuper votre de votre grand-mère qui
était souffrant
et là vous décrivez la violence terrible
et cruelle de votre cousin qui était
venu en France
vous étiez seul avec lui dans
l'appartement familial
cet homme vous a violé insulté il a même
filmé l'axe en disant que vous lui
apparteniez
et malgré les appels à l'aide auprès de
votre famille personne ne vous croyez et
cet homme est accueilli comme un roi
comment comment vous expliquer le fait
que que votre parole n'avait pas
d'importance vis-à-vis de cet homme
plus une femme on ne croit pas la femme
c'est l'homme qui
chez les rois qui décide qui
va pas pouvoir sur la femme comment ça
se passe au quotidien je sais pas par
exemple dans votre travail je sais pas
si on peut en parler c'est très
difficile c'est difficile j'ai dû
changer de travail
quand il y avait beaucoup d'hommes où je
me sentais pas bien
je me sentais mal étouffé
et j'ai l'impression de revoir
de quoi que ce soit encore aujourd'hui
vous trouvez vous avez des doutes
là-dessus
je me dis j'ai forcément fait quelque
chose
[Musique]
pour en arriver là pour
et pourtant j'ai toujours été droite
j'ai toujours
et il y a aussi ce moment où à l'hôpital
vous allez pour des problèmes de santé
et
le médecin vous apprend que vous êtes
enceinte de votre cousin
vous aviez le sentiment de porter
l'enfant du diable
et vous parlez dans le livre de la de la
culpabilité de cet avortement vous avez
dû faire ce que vous pouvez me dire
davantage par rapport à ça
j'ai fait quelque chose de grave
je pense que je n'avais pas le choix
c'est
si mon cousin le récit va
[Musique]
nourriture soit je serai encore avec lui
de force
ici la prend que j'ai avorté de son
enfant et
et il est capable de tout
l'enfant du diable
et à la fin du livre vous dites
qu'écrire ça a été votre thérapie vous
n'aviez plus que votre plume comme ami
vous écrivez dans le livre
qu'est-ce que ça a présenté d'écrire ce
livre pour vous
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses
honnêtement je pensais pas être encore
encore là au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand j'ai écrit
mon histoire c'est je pensais vraiment à
me
mettre fin à ma vie
j'ai envoyé tout ça ma meilleure amie
pour le cintre
et justement vous en parler aujourd'hui
vous avez un mari vous avez un enfant
avec ce mari aussi
c'est eux qui vous donne la force
d'avancer aussi
quel est le message que vous voudriez
faire passer aux femmes qui qui vivent
parce que vous avez vécu
adorent
ne pas avoir honte
ne pas se sentir coupable surtout
surtout parler
merci beaucoup merci pour pour ce
témoignage que vous nous avez livré
aujourd'hui merci et pour pour ce livre
que vous avez écrit
merci infiniment à vous